so ich begrüße sie zur letzten sitzung
in diesem semester und wir haben uns die
letzte sitzung etwas ganz besonderes
vorgenommen nämlich wir werden uns heute
mit dem porträt beschäftigen und seinen
stift das sein und das nichts
aber bevor wir zu diesen sehr
interessanten willkommen müssen wir uns
noch mal zurück beziehen auf ein land
und philosophen der so aussieht und der
immanuel kant heißt und der eine ganz
wichtige schrift verfasst hat mit dem
titel kritik der reinen vernunft wollen
dieser schrift hat er versucht freiheit
und determination durch die natur
zusammen zu denken
also man kann das in gewisser weise an
kompatibel ist muss nennen aber es ist
kein gewöhnlicher kompatibles muss
sondern es eine spezielle form von
kompatibel ist muss und zwar deswegen
weil die frage ob freiheit und
determination durch die natur
miteinander kompatibel sind davon
abhängt wie wir die zeit verstehen also
es hängt damit zusammen wie wir die
grundstrukturen der welt verstehen
können und ob unser verständnis der
grundstrukturen es uns erlaubt natur
kausalität mit freiheits kausalität
sondern kann diese kausalität zusammen
zu denken
und man nimmt diese art von philosophie
pikant vertritt einem transzendentalen
idealismus
idealismus und das hatten wir schon mal
einmal eingeführt als zentraler
idealismus bedeutet die bedingungen der
möglichkeit von erkenntnis dass mein
trans zentral also das überhaupt
erkenntnis möglich ist die hängen vom
subjekt der erkenntnis ab das heißt
konkret darauf gewendet das thema zeit
zeit und raum kann nur durch bezug auf
die erkenntnis subjektivität verstanden
werden das ist jetzt ein weiterführendes
thema was wir nicht wissen das letzte
detail jetzt hier klären können habe es
objektiv fest zeit und raum existieren
nicht objektiv unabhängig vom subjekt
der erkenntnis sie dürfen sie das
subjekt jetzt nicht als ein empirisches
subjekt vorstellen als sein so wie wir
es jetzt hier sind ist eine besondere
form von subjektivität die kanten
transzendentale nimmt wir wollen jetzt
nicht weiter ins detail gehen aber ich
will nur soviel sagen die auflösung
dieser antinori und die antenne war eben
die entweder alles ist determiniert
naturgesetzlich und das ist irgendwie
unbefriedigend weil es keinen absoluten
ersten anfang an gibt und dann müssen
wir irgendwie denken damit die reihe
überhaupt sinnvoll wird und diese andere
these dass eben noch eine zusätzliche
form von kausalität angenommen werden
muss
die vertragen sich nur dann wenn wir
gewisse unterscheidungen noch einführen
die damit zusammenhängen vor allem der
zeit und dann sagt wenn wir diese
unterscheidung machen dann kriegen wir
das ganze zusammen
dann können wir also freiheit und
determinismus so zusammen denken dass
sie sich nicht in die quere kommen
als er sucht jetzt für determinismus
durch die natur und freiheit einen platz
in einem gefüge so dass das geflügel
nicht widersprüchlich ist das ist der
punkt
und auf diesem weg dorthin zu diesem
kompatibel ist muss ich schreibe in
anführungsstrichen weil es kein
gewöhnlicher kompatibel ist muss ist
weil gewöhnliche kompatibel ismen nicht
an der zeit hatte sie würden sagen wir
haben kein anderes zeitverständnis die
zeit ist objektiv oder wie auch immer
aber nicht vom subjekt abhängig die
gängigen kompatibel ist unterscheiden
sich von dem kantischen kompanie bildnis
muss stark sodass man auch manchmal
erkannt als einen inkompatible listen
bezeichnen könnte weil er ganz klar sagt
freiheit und determination können nicht
auf derselben ebene angesetzt also der
clou ist eigentlich folgendes wir können
nicht auf derselben ebene freiheiten
determinismus ansetzen
das will aber gerade der moderne
kompatibel ismus der wildes sein kann
sagt wir müssen zwei ebenen ansetzen
freiheit und natur determination wenn
wir das jetzt so determination auf zwei
verschiedenen ebenen dann wäre es eher
einigen inkompatibel ismus sind die
nicht verträglich miteinander aber kann
versucht jetzt folgendes sagen er
versuchte zu zeigen dass wir das
irgendwie zusammenhängen könnte dass
sich die enden hier schließen
so muss man sich das vorstellen und das
ist jetzt die ganz spannende frage wie
das gelingt also freiheit und der termin
ist muss einerseits nicht auf derselben
ebene auf zwei verschiedenen ebenen
aber die zwei verschiedenen ebenen
werden so zusammen gedacht dass sie sich
ineinander fügen dass sie zusammen
gedacht werden können sie zwei ebenen
werden nicht auf die selben ebene geholt
aber sie werden ein komplexes ganz
integriert und darin irgendwie
erträglich gemacht mit gewissen
unterscheidungen die die zeit betreffen
den raum betreffen die dann so eine
zusammenfügung möglich machen
und das ist natürlich eine sehr wie sie
sich denken eine sehr anspruchsvolle
aufgabe
wir wollen jetzt schauen ob kann das
hinbekommt oder jedenfalls wie ihr seht
mal versucht also wie gelingt es im
freiheits natur kausalität zusammen zu
denken ist ganz positioniere kompatibel
ist ish oder liberta realistisch zu
nennen es auch eine spannende frage für
eine hausarbeit zum beispiel inwiefern
ist kann ein kompatibel ist ganz
spannende frage und jetzt kommen wir zu
der auflösung der kosmologischen ideen
also dieser antinori ist der vernunft
und da will ich jetzt einfach mal ein
bisschen reinlesen ich hoffe sie können
es einigermaßen lesen ich krieg leider
die vorhänge nicht zu das gerät hat
versagt
also sie können zuhören und ich habe
auch die folien vom letzten mal haben
sie ja noch das hätten sie ja noch vor
sich also er sagt wenn erscheinungen
dinge an sich selbst wären mit den raum
und zeit form des daseins der dinge an
sich selbst so würden die bedingungen
mit dem bedingten jederzeit als leader
zu einer unter selben reihe gehören und
daraus auch im gegenwärtigen fall die
antinori entspringen die allen trans
zentrale ideen gemein ist dass diese rey
unvermeidlich für den verstand zu groß
oder zu klein ausfallen müsste die
dynamischen vernunft begriffe aber mit
denen wir uns in dieser und der
folgenden nummer beschäftigen haben
dieses besondere das dass sie es nicht
mit einem gegenstand der als größe
betrachtet sondern nur mit einem dasein
zu tun haben man auch von der größe der
reisebedingungen abstrahieren kann und
es bei ihnen bloß auf das dynamische
verhältnis der bedingung zum bedingten
ankommen so dass wir in der frage über
natur und freiheit schon die
schwierigkeit antreffen opfer hält
überall
möglich sei und ob wenn sie es ist sie
mit der allgemeinheit das naturgesetz
die kausalität zusammen bestehen können
mithin ob es ein richtig dies jung
tiefer satz sei das eine jede wirkung in
der welt entweder aus natur- oder
ausfall entspringen müsse oder ob nicht
vielmehr beides in verschiedener
beziehung bei einer und derselben
begebenheit zugleich stattfinden können
das ist jetzt die entscheidende frage
also hier sind zwei ganz wichtige
informationen enthalten
erst mal am anfang sagt er wenn
erscheinung und dinge an sich sind als
erscheinung ist das was wir eben
sinnlich wahrnehmen jetzt hier was geht
was uns in unsere sinnesorgane einströmt
wenn das die dinge an sich selbst wären
und die objektiven dinge dann sagt kann
dann könnten wir nicht freiheit und
determinismus zusammendenken kompa
touristisch und diese ansicht dass die
erscheinung also was uns ziemlich
gegeben ist dass das die dinge wie sie
wirklich sind repräsentiert diese
auffassung nennt man trans zentralen
realismus also dass zum beispiel die
zeit und der raum eben unabhängig vom
subjekt der erkenntnis sind und das will
kann gerade nichts mehr sagt wir
vertreten einen trans and arlen
idealismus also die erscheinungen sind
nicht mit den dingen an sich selbst
gleich zu setzen
hier spielt noch eine subjektivität eine
rolle genommen den spiel kommt das ist
eine das deutet jetzt schon so ein
bisschen auf diese auflösung hin
das müsse noch genauer schauen wir uns
am schluss aber noch entscheiden denn
diesem zitat ist mir dieser satz als ob
es ein richtig des jungen tiefer sei
wie verstehen was ist denn ein
destruktiver satz wissen sie das noch
aus der logik weil es denn eine
dysfunktion
wissen sie noch wie das zeigen fand
diese funktion aussieht in der logik ja
so einfach also oder brie oder b das
problem ist bei der diskussion dass das
häufig auch als grund oder gelesen wird
also müssen dass ein entweder-oder also
eine richtige ist um tiefe ist ein
richtiges jung tiefer satz ist a oder b
und nicht a und b zu klein
also die frage ob das ein richtig des
kiefers hat sei es heißt es ist wirklich
so dass wir nur entweder freiheit oder
determinismus haben können oder ist es
nicht doch möglich dass beides zugleich
unter einem gewissen gesichtspunkt
möglich ist dass ist sie entspannt auf
eine frage das ist sozusagen die frage
nach dem kompatibel ist muss das ist die
frage nach kompatibel ist muss oder
inkompatiblen muss und wir haben jetzt
hier den hinweis auf die auflösung ob
nicht vielmehr beides also freiheit und
natur die präsentation in verschiedener
beziehung bei einer unterseen
begebenheit zugleich stattfinden können
gäste spannende also möchte zeigen dass
ein und derselben handlungen aber ein
oder derselben handlung die wir
vollziehen
das ereignis zum beispiel eine handlung
von uns aus zwei gesichtspunkten
betrachtet werden kann einmal aus dem
gesichtspunkt der natur determination
und für gesamtes handeln sagt kann lässt
sich natur der feministisch erklären
können bis ins unendliche kette
zurückgehen
das entsprach sprangen aus diesem
stahlen gesetze kausalen einfluss und
dieser wiederum aus dem vorherigen da
werden wir nie freiheit finden kann
aber es gibt noch eine andere
perspektive aus der wir unsere
handlungen
betrachten können vielleicht nicht so
sehr erklären aber eher verstehen sie
kennen alle die unterscheidung zwischen
verstehen und erklären geht auch wlan
dilthey zurück und er sagte erklären das
tun die naturwissenschaften und
verstehen dass die geisteswissenschaften
ist ein mal wenn ich etwas erkläre gebe
ich ursachen an
und wenn sie etwas verstehen gebe ich
gründe an also motive usw und kann sagt
wir können als ein und dieselbe sache
zum beispiel eine menschliche handlung
aus naturgesetzlich
naturwissenschaftliche perspektive
vollständig beschreiben und wir können
sie aber auch noch zugleich aus einer
freiheits perspektive betrachten nämlich
dass dann noch gründe mit eine rolle
gespielt haben also motive maximen
willens entscheidungen und so weiter und
so fort
und jetzt ist die spannende frage wie
man diese verschiedene beziehung wie man
die verstehen muss die verschiedenen
beziehungen habe ich damit schon
veranschaulicht dass ich gesagt habe
sind zwei ebenen die aber zusammen
gedacht und das wollen wir jetzt schauen
ob das kann jetzt gelingt haben sie dazu
eine rückfrage ist ihnen die
fragestellung klar worum es geht also
möchte irgendwie manche forscher sagen
auch oder ein kant forscher hat mal
gesagt kann möchte einen kompatibel ist
muss entwickeln von kompatibel ist muss
und inkompatibel ist
ich möchte ein kompatibles und
inkompatible muss kompatibel denke das
war der m-watch gibt es auch ein aufsatz
der zwei spannende frage was für eine
art wenn überhaupt von kompatibel ist
muss vertritt kann man kann natürlich
jetzt gleich sein ja er vertritt einen
transzendentalen kompatibel ist
das wäre vielleicht eine gute gute
antwort kein gewöhnlicher kompatibles
muss sondern ein spezieller ein
transplantat und wie dieser
transzendentale kompatibles muss jetzt
aussieht das werden wir sehen ihr hängt
ebenfalls davon ab dass erscheinungen
nicht dinge an sich selbst zins dass wir
hier zwei ebenen auseinander halten
müssen
und jetzt fragt ihr hier es ist also nur
die frage ob in anziehung eben derselben
wirkung die nach der natur bestimmt ist
auch freiheit stattfinden könne
oder diese durch jene und verletzliche
regel völlig ausgeschlossen sei ist also
die frage dieses kompatibel
und hier zeigt die zwar gemeinhin aber
betrübliche voraussetzungen die
absoluten realität erscheinung zugleich
ihren nachteiligen einfluss die vernunft
zu verwirren
denn sind erscheinungen dinge an sich
selbst so ist freiheit nicht zu retten
als dann ist die natur die vollständige
und haben sich hinreichend bestimmende
ursache jeder begebenheit und die
bedingung der cell press die derzeit nur
in der reihe erscheinung enthalten die
samt ihrer wirkung unter dem
naturgesetze notwendig sind also haben
sie aus diesem zitat jetzt eine
information ziehen könnte uns ein
bisschen mehr auskunft gibt über die
auflösung dieser antinori haben sie da
einen hinweis bekommen
woran hängt das ganze jetzt ist ganz
bekanntes zitat ist das hier denn sind
erscheinungen dinge an sich selbst so
ist die freiheit nicht zu retten
als wir müssen unterscheiden die welt
wie sie nur in der erscheinung für uns
ist und die welt wie sie an sich ist und
er sagt absolute realität der
erscheinung
die diese annahme dass die erscheinungen
so wie sie aufgenommen werden und dass
die absolute realität haben absolut
realität man unabhängig vom subjekt
gültigkeit an die sagt bekannt ist sehr
nachteilig die ist sehr problematisch
sagt haben und wir müssen jetzt weiter
lesen und schauen wie kant dieses
problem löst also wenn die erscheinende
an sich selbst sagt er dann ist freiheit
nicht zu beenden
und jetzt kommt der anschluss hier unten
wenn dagegen
also wir dürfen jetzt nicht die
erscheinung für die dinge an sich selbst
halten
wir müssen jetzt unterscheidung treffen
und jetzt sagt wenn dagegen die
erscheinungen als was wir wahrnehmen in
raum und zeit wenn die für nichts mehr
gelten als sie in der tat sind nämlich
nicht für dinge an sich sondern lose
vorstellungen die nach empirischen
gesetzen zusammenhängen
so müssen sie selbst noch gründe haben
die nicht erscheinungen sind eine solche
interne sache aber wird in anziehung
ihrer kausalität
nicht durch erscheinen bestimmt zwar
ihre wirkungen erscheinen und sie durch
andere erscheinungen bestimmt werden
können
sie ist also samt ihrer kausalität außer
der reihe
außer der reihe meint
diese und eligible ursache die mit der
freiheit zusammengebracht wird die ist
außer der reihe der natur determination
das also auf einer anderen ebene haben
wir das jetzt hier dargestellt
[Musik]
außer der reihe dagegen ihre wirkungen
in der reihe der empirischen bedingungen
angetroffen werden
das ist also spannend also was muss ich
jetzt machen in diesem bild wenn er
jetzt sagt die wirkungen werden in der
reihe an getroffen was muss jetzt machen
wenn jetzt also hier das da oben das ist
freiheit oder interne sache unter die
ursache meint ist eine ursache die nicht
nicht empirisch es ist zum beispiel so
was wie gründe gute motive was muss ich
jetzt hier in diesem bild machen um zu
veranschaulichen dass die will kommt der
intel plane sache in der reit
empirischen bedingung dass diese drei
angetroffen werden kann was muss jetzt
hier machen
das muss jetzt ein zeichnen
viel als irgendein übergang herstellen
als ich muss einfach ein teil erst mal
so hier ein zeichen also von mir geht in
diesem teil darunter hat jedenfalls die
willkommen der freiheits kausalität die
werden auch bringt der reihe
erscheinungen ich kann auch noch scheint
erscheinung der reihe erscheinungen da
drücken die sich aus also sie müssen
jetzt so verstehen
es gibt eine intelligente sache das kann
jetzt zum beispiel ein motiv seien ein
grund sein
der ist nicht empirisch bestimmt und der
wirkt sich aber kausal und er macht sich
bemerkbar
am ende in der reihe erscheinung woran
haben sie ein beispiel wie man das
erklären kann wie kann sich so eine
intelligente ursache in der reihe
erscheinungen manifestieren
geben sie mir ein beispiel das machen
sie ständig so gar nicht jetzt sind
diese moment mache das wo ich jetzt rede
der manifestiert sich eine integre sache
hinter erscheinung nach kant jedenfalls
dem
merck notiert ist ein hobby
denken wir
ja also es ist so die natur ursachen
die hängen das ist der punkt die hängen
mit der zeitlichkeit zusammen alles was
hier in der natur sich ereignet ereignet
sich in der zeit unser sukzessive und
das muss man auch dazusagen diese
intelligente sache die ereignet sich
nach kant nicht in der zeit das ist der
entscheidende punkt
die ist nicht zeitlich und weil die
intelligente sache nicht zeitlich ist
sie darf nicht zeitlich gedacht werden
wir müssen uns jetzt noch überlegen
inwiefern man eine indigene ursache als
nicht zeitlich sich vorstellen kann
weil sie nicht zeitlich ist konflikt
irrt sie nicht mit dieser art von
ursächlichkeit die zeitlich ist das ist
ja eigentlich klar also ich habe einmal
solche entität oder was auch immer
phänomene die nicht zeitlich sind und
die müssen zusammengebracht werden mit
etwas was zeitliches das heißt jetzt
noch nicht dass es damit zusammen
gebracht werden können oder wie genau
sie damit zusammengebracht werden können
aber sie lassen sich auf jeden fall
besser zusammenbringen weil sie nicht
auf derselben ebene miteinander
konferieren
wir haben es einmal mit einer zeitlosen
ordnung zu tun und aber mit einer
zeitlichen ordnung dass der erste
schritt und der zweite schritt wird sein
dass die zeit nicht objektives ist was
in der welt vorkommt unabhängig von uns
erkennen zu bieten sondern dass die zeit
selbst mit dem erkennen zu blick zu tun
hat als die zeit selbst ist wieder so
ein bisschen rück gebunden an dieses
zentrale zu bieten und mit dieser
unterscheidung dass es sagt einmal haben
wir mit etwas zeitlichem zu tun nämlich
mit den erscheinen wie sie in der welt
sich ereignen und einmal nicht zb mit
intensiven ursachen
das ist so eine möglichkeit der
vereinigung beider aber jetzt noch mal
zurück auf diese frage nach ein beispiel
nach einer auswirkung eines eines
phänomens in der erscheinung
ich gebe ihn beispiel ein intelligenter
grund wäre zum beispiel eine ein zweck
den ich mir setze eine maxime ganz und
gar man ganz klaren fall zu nehmen eine
moralische handlung sehe eine bedürftige
person oder eine verletzte person und
meinem gewissen der kategorische
imperativ gebietet mir jetzt dazu helfen
irgendwas zu tun oder meine maximen
werden jetzt hier angewendet dann ist
das motiv für die handlung da sich diese
person helfen es ist ein integrer grund
eligible ursache aber diese integrierte
die manifestiert sich am ende in der
erscheinung ich gehe hin in der zeit ich
helfe dieser person das kann man alles
dann sehen sozusagen was da das ist
auswirkt von dieser intelligenten
ursache dass mein kind einfach nur damit
eigentlich alles was wir hier tun auch
dass wir jetzt hier miteinander
kommunizieren dass sie mich hören dass
ich etwas hoffentlich intelligenz oder
intelligentes dass die frage ob
irgendwas was ich mir ebenfalls gedacht
habe da sich das kommuniziere in raum
und zeit und raum und zeit setzte das
ist die auswirkung des eigentlich nach
kant zeitlosen in der zeit da sind
natürlich nicht hundertprozentig klar
ein motiv von mir zum beispiel dass ich
irgendwie das ich philosophie mag dass
ich ideale habe dass ich nach dem ersten
lied schrieb sowas ja das ist nicht ganz
so einfach weil es könnte auch ein grund
dahinter sein
bekannt ist es eine schwierige frage der
nicht intelligent nicht genannt werden
kann
nach kant wäre das zum beispiel dann der
fall wenn ich philosophie nur machen
würde um irgendwie genutzt zu haben
empirischen genuss die frage ist ob das
philosophie überhaupt schaffen kann
empirischen genuss eigentlich er gerade
er nicht also finanziell zumindest nicht
oder auch sonstige bringt philosophie
eigentlich ihr viel eher leid empirische
sleipner arbeit zum beispiel wenn ich
jetzt nur philosophie gemacht hätte um
anderen zu imponieren
oder um irgendwie berühmt zu werden was
eher unwahrscheinlich sagen aber nur um
solche äußeren äußerlichkeiten zu
erreichen also um empirischen genuss zu
haben das müsste empirischer genutzt
sagt den ich damit bezweckte was bei
philosophie nicht unmöglich ist aber
selbst das wäre möglich dann wäre das
nach kant kein in die ursache oder
zumindest dass es die frage ob dieses
motiv der empirischen genusses ob das
als eine intelligenten kann oder ob ich
darin nicht einfach nur mein natur
natürlichen neigungen unterliegen also
was die gründe sind sind es am ende nur
sachen dass ich durch meine natur
bedürfnis es so determiniert bin dass
ich gar keine intelligenten ursachen
ausbilden kann kann intuitiven gründe
ausbilden kann das eine spannende frage
aber wenn ich mich bewusst dazu
entscheide ein zweck verfolgt ein ziel
habe darüber nachgedacht habe aus
freiheit dann wäre das verkannten der
regel ein integrer sache und die macht
sich natürlich in der empirischen
wirklichkeit dann bemerkbar indem ich
irgendwie im raum laufe in dem ich
artikulieren in dem ich mich mit der
natur gesetzlichkeit unterstelle
jetzt müssen wir das noch ein bisschen
weiter lesen war jetzt sagt er hier
da sitzt ein entscheidender satz die
wirkung die wirkung ist jetzt also das
was auf der ebene der erscheinungen
stattfinden als in der indie-szene
realität in raum und zeit die wirkung
einer intelligent ursache kann also in
ansehung ihrer intelligenten ursache als
frei und doch zugleich in ansehung der
erscheinungen als erfolg aus denselben
nach der notwendigkeit der natur
angesehen werden eine unterscheidung die
wenn sie im allgemeinen und ganz
abstrakt vorgetragen wird so wie jetzt
äußerst subtil und dunkel sein muss die
sich aber in der anwendung aufklären
wird
hier habe ich nur die anmerkung machen
wollen dass da der durchgängige
zusammenhang alle erscheinungen in einem
kontext der natur einen nachlass liches
gesetz ist dieses alle freiheit
notwendig umstürzen müsste wenn man die
realität der erscheinungen der
erscheinungen hartnäckig anhängen wollte
daher auch diejenigen wir hier in der
gemeinde meinung folgen niemals dahin
haben gelangen können natur und freiheit
miteinander zu vereinigen
also er formuliert die 1 kompatibel ist
isches projekt und es sagt dieses
projekt der vereinigung von natur und
freiheit natur kausalität und freiheit
kausalität klappt nur dann wenn man
nicht die erscheinungen für dinge an
sich also wenn man nicht die zeit für
etwas objektives ansetzen sondern muss
die zeit als etwas ansehen was
sich der subjektivität verdanken und man
muss davon ausgehen dass freiheit selbst
nicht es ist was in der erscheinung
stattfindet das ist so der punkt und
jetzt haben wir jedenfalls eine wichtige
unterscheidung getroffen
aber es ist natürlich noch nicht ganz
klar wie jetzt beiden zusammengebracht
werden können also nochmal das ist der
zentrale satz die wirkung zum beispiel
eine konkrete bearishe handlung kann in
anziehung ihrer intensiven ursachen
meine motive in meiner gründe meiner
freiheit überlegungen als erfolg aus
denselben nach der notwendigkeit der
natur angesehen werden als frei dann
soll die lieben oder sache als frei und
doch zugleich als ihm der schon als
erfolg also jede handlung kann ich
sowohl jede handlung von mir als vom
wesen kann ich sowohl als etwas
verstehen was durch freiheit realisiert
wurde als auch als etwas was durch natur
gesetzlichkeit bestimmt das also wir
sind sozusagen über determiniert in
unseren handlungen
wir können die handlung sowohl
naturgesetz nicht beschreiben und zwar
vollständig und deswegen ist er kein
klassischer kompatibel ist jedenfalls
also nicht ganz exakt und wir können sie
aber auch aus einer anderen perspektive
betrachten nämlich unter der zeitlosen
perspektive der freiheit als etwas was
durch gründe und maximen und sonstige
intelligent sachen bestimmt wurde
es ist so eine art von kompatibel ist
aber nicht genau weil er eben hier nicht
alles auf einer der selben ebene
ansetzen zwei ebenen unterscheiden
und jetzt ist die spannende frage wie
können wir hier natur und freiheit
miteinander vereinigen also wie können
wir diese zwei ebenen zusammen bringen
wie können wir diese zwei ebenen
ineinander denken sodass sie sich nicht
widersprechen
ein hinweis habe ich schon geben der
hinweis ist der derzeit das eine die
freiheit die interviewer sache ist
zeitlos
und das in der natur determination sich
ereignete ist zeitlich haben sie ein
mögliches argument dafür dass die
intuitive ursache zeitlos ist wie können
wir uns intern als etwas zeitloses
vorstellen überlegen sie mal was war
nochmal beispiele für intelligenten was
hatten wir uns darüber legt maximen
genau oder gründe und so weiter
inwiefern können gründe und maxim
zeitlos sein
die spannende frage ja das wäre die
möglichkeit dass sie ja dass wir eine
möglichkeit sie haben uns überlegt dass
ich so ein absoluter anfangs sind sie
jedenfalls müssen sie so gedacht werden
aber überlegen sie beim alltag wenn sie
eine maxime haben
das ist nochmal eine maxi meine maxime
ist ein subjektiver handlungs grundsatz
als eine grundsatz überzeugung nachdem
sie handeln die handlung die nach einer
maxime erfolg die ist empirisch die ist
in der zeit oder handlungen die nach der
maxime folgend sind in der zeit aber ist
die maxime dann so in der zeit wie die
handlungen die auf see an springen wohl
eher nicht alle die an die maxime delikt
wir alle handlungen zu grunde
sie haben die maxime einmal gewählt und
da ist es dann auch gar nicht so
entscheidend wann sie die gewählt haben
sollen sie haben die und sie legt wie
gesagt allen handlungen zum grunde aber
indem sie allen handlungen zum grunde
liegt ist sie eigentlich wissen vom
zeitlos sie ist ja so ein prinzip aus
dem dann die handlung reduziert werden
die dann in der zeit stattfinden die
maxime hält sich in der zeit durch sie
erstreckt sich sie fundiert alle
handlungen die so ein prinzip aber das
prinzip als solches das ist jetzt nicht
zu einem bestimmten zeitpunkt da oder
nicht sondern ist immer da in einer
gewissen weise handlungen die werden
immer mal wieder vollzogen zu einem
bestimmten zeitpunkt die fliesen aus
diesem an dieser maxime aber wir
überlegen uns nicht bei jeder handlung
aufs neue
sollen wir jetzt die maxime anwenden
oder nicht sondern wenn wir den maximen
haben dann haben wir die gesetzt und wir
wenden sie vielleicht immer wieder an
aber die anwendung der maxime
ja nicht die maxime selbst die anwendung
der maxime ist vielleicht ein
empirischer sachverhalt aber die geltung
der maxime vielleicht müsste man das
auch besser hier mit der geltung
verdeutlichen die geltung der maxime die
zeitlos letztendlich ja jedenfalls nicht
in dieser logik zu denken wie die
einzelnen handlungen die mal erscheinen
oder mal nicht erscheinen die mal
verzogen werden man nicht die maxime
wird nicht vollzogen und nicht verzogen
sie wird mal gewählt und die frage ist
ob der akt des wählens eine maxime
zeitlich zu verstehen ist schwieriger
punkt aber wenn sie einmal gewählt ist
dann hat sie eigentlich nicht nur eine
zeitliche logik würde ich sagen sind sie
hat zum prinzip ist ein prinzip was
überall meinen handlungen schwebt und
was ich eben immer mal wieder
verwirklich empirischer so könnte man
sich das vorstellen schwieriger punkt
jedenfalls kann würde auch sagen
eigentlich können wir uns die
intelligent ursachen gar nicht empirisch
verständlich machen aber wir brauchen
der trotzdem gewisse anhaltspunkte so
ein angebot also sagen maxxim oder
gründe
die haben eine andere form von geld um
als sie empirische handlungen oder
sonstige ereignisse haben also das ist
jetzt sagen der punkt wir müssen wir
müssen die internet libyen gründe
die müssen wir also eine art von
substanz betrachten eine substanz die
zeitlos ist sein fundament und die
erscheinung müssen wir als ein ausdruck
als ein in der zeit stattfinden
ausdrucksformen dieser gründe verstehen
und wenn wir das so verstehen also wieso
nur bild und abbild wenn also die
erscheinung nur so abbildungen sind so
zeitlich abbildungen und prinzipien
dann würde das nach kant passen weil
dann sind die integrierten gründe
außerhalb der zeit und insofern sie
außerhalb der zeit sind gerichts einer
anderen logik sind also jetzt als solche
erst mal nicht einen kontrast stehend
oder gegensatz stehen zur
logik der zeitlich geordneten
naturerscheinung also man kann sich das
vielleicht so vorstellen
wir haben hier die ursachenkette und
dies in der zeit weil hier zeitlich
gestreckt und die ist aber also die
ursachenkette ist wenn derzeit abhängig
aber die zeit ist nicht objektiv und die
zeit ist eine reine anschauungs form das
objekt wird also man könnte es so sagen
die wird also eigentlich hier so
zurückgezogen
zu diesen zum intelligent und das ist
eigentlich nur ein ausdruck zeitlichen
kapazitäten sind nur ein ausdruck in der
rhein anschauungs von derzeit die selbst
auch jetzt endlich mehr mit diesem
intelligenten photon hat weil es mit dem
tierischen gesetzt und versucht
darzustellen
also die zeit ist hier hängt damit
zusammen mit dem intelligent auf eine
gewisse weise und das ist zeitlos
deswegen mache ich das diese kreis dass
die bedingung der möglichkeit der zeit
und die ganzen gründe die manifestieren
sich in den erscheinungen
obwohl sie selbst nicht zeitlich sind ja
das ist jetzt in aller kürze ein versuch
dieser auflösung dieser auflösung zu
erklären also wichtig ist hier dass zeit
nichts objektives ist eine zeit geben
eigentlich auch hier in diesen bereich
gehört und da die erscheinungen ihr ein
ausdruck sind ein abbild und die gründe
eher ein urbild es geht um urbild abbild
verhältnisse wie so eine substanz die
eine gewisse oberfläche hat oberfläche
mag wandeln sich wandeln auch in der
zeit aber die substanz ist sagen das
beharren als allem zugrunde liegt so
kann man sich das
wie eine maxime all ihren handlungen die
verschieden sein können von von ihrer
art zu grunde liegt sie können also nach
einem aktive ganz verschiedene
handlungen je nach situation je nach
zeitlichen umständen vollziehen aber die
maxime bleibt ist die maxime ist
gewissermaßen die substanz und die
handlungen sind gewissermaßen das
akzidenz was eben zeitlich auch sich von
seiner gestalt verändern kann
das ist so der gedanke als fundierung
zusammenhang und damit handel
jedenfalls nur ein fingerzeig geben und
deswegen würde ich sagen kann es kein
anerkannt ist kein kompatibel ist im
klassischen sinne weil er eben sagt dass
freiheit und determinismus nicht auf
derselben ebene angesiedelt sind sie
sind auf zwei ebenen angesiedelt und das
wäre jetzt eher so eine form von
inkompatibel ist muss sind nicht
kompatibel miteinander die sind nicht
auf derselben ebene angesiedelt aber sie
lassen sich trotzdem zusammen denken
wenn wir gewisse unterscheidung machen
wie die subjektivität derzeit die
zeitlosigkeit diese gründe und dieses
ausdrucks abbild verhältnis von beiden
ich werde es in der zusammenfassung noch
ein bisschen ausführlicher schreiben
das ist jetzt auch sehr fortgeschritten
was wir machen aber nur dass ich mal
sehen bei kant fällte die sache nochmal
viel komplizierter als es die
gewöhnlichen unterscheidungen schon die
wir hier im seminar kennen gelernt haben
also kann als einfachen kompatibel ist
darzustellen geht jedenfalls nicht ich
würde schon sagen kann diesen kompatibel
ist aber eher ein transzendentaler
kompatibel ist er mit seinem kompatibles
muss bestimmte revisionen an unserem die
üblichen zeitverständnis anbringen muss
man kann aber auch dafür argumentieren
dass kannten die portaner ist kann man
auch tun
aber dann muss man halt wiederum sagen
er vertritt seien die beta realismus
nicht auf basis eines in der termin is
muss man verkannt alles zugleich
determiniert ist ja könnte auch sagen
eine botanische kompatibles muss man sie
verwenden auch solche ausdrücke
jedenfalls wäre das ein spannendes thema
von der ausarbeitung fragen inwiefern
ist kant 1 kompatibel ist wirklich mit
anderen kompatibel ist und die wir
kennen gelernt
dessen spannende fragen haben sie noch
fragen zu dieser sache ja
[Musik]
es kam auch zu einigen
lösung
[Musik]
das heißt hier diese arbeiten
genau
dass das ist richtig kann sagt in der
kritik der reinen vernunft aus diesem
werk stammt diese ganze tat er möchte
nur die denkt möglichkeit aufzeigen der
vereinbarkeit von freiheit und natur
kausalität also nur die logische
möglichkeit aber nicht die wirklichkeit
er zeigt hier nicht dass es wirklich so
ist zeigt nur dass es denkbar so denkt
man wird das ganze deswegen weil wir
eben hier in der freiheit ist nicht mit
zeitlichen ereignissen zu tun haben mit
diesen gründen intelligenz endlich
zeitlich verfasst und die haben wir es
mit der zeit und deswegen aufgrund
dieser unterscheidung der verschiedenen
formen von zeitlichkeit oder die nicht
zeitlichkeit ist es logisch möglich dass
beide zugleich existieren können dass
also eine us eine handlung oder ein
ereignis erscheinung sowohl durch das
naturgesetz vollständig bestimmt ist als
auch eben zugleich durch gründe der
intrigen ursache die nicht zeitlich sind
das ist logisch möglich und dann hat er
aber die kritik der praktischen vernunft
das ist sein nächstes werk und da
versucht dann kann zu lesen ich bin
jedenfalls er sagt es auch an manchen
stellen versucht kann dann die
wirklichkeit des kompatibel ismus von
freiheit und natur kausalität zu zeigen
und zwar haben wir hier schon so einen
kleinen einen kleinen hinweis bekannt
sagt dass diese ganzen betrachtungen die
ihr hier macht das die eigentlich dunkel
sind also hier eine unterscheidung
das ist diese unterscheidung die wir
hier vor vollzogen haben ist eine
unterscheidung die wenn sie im
allgemeinen und ganz abstrakt
vorgetragen wird äußerst subtil und
dunkel erscheinen muss da befinden wir
uns jetzt in diesem zustand es ist toll
so subtil und dunkel die sich aber in
der anwendung aufklären wird und
letztlich frage was ist die anwendung
die anwendung ist natürlich so scheint
es jedenfalls der bezug auf eine
konkrete handlung und zwar eine
moralische handlung und das macht dann
kann nicht mehr in der kritik der reinen
vernunft sondern der kritik der
praktischen vernunft und da sagte auch
ganz ausdrücklich wir müssen diese
unterscheidung auf den begriff des
willens beziehen und so begibt des
willens und wenn wir das ganze auf den
begriff des willens beziehen dann können
wir nämlich die einheit von beiden
aufzeigen weil der wille sowohl durch
natur ursachen bestimmbar ist als auch
durch intelligente bestimmt war ist im
willen soll jedenfalls meine
interpretation im willen können wir
diese abstrakte unterscheidung
aufeinander konkretisieren
ja der bildungsbegriff hat seine
doppelseitig kite wir können unseren
willen durch tierische motive bestimmen
lassen
wir können unseren willen durch
intelligent motive bestimmen lassen der
wille ist die klammer die beides
zusammen bringt ist jedenfalls meine
lesart kant hatte auch einige beispiele
sagt diese ganze abstrakte
unterscheidung der kritik der reinen
vernunft die wird völlig klar wenn wir
sie auf den willens begriff beziehen
[Musik]
jetzt denkt möglichkeit also es gibt bei
kann zwei verschiedene formen von
möglichkeiten es gibt die eben die
logische möglichkeit und es gibt daneben
die trans zentrale möglichkeit oder noch
eine andere als er meint wirklich die
alle abstrakte möglichkeiten
hat die vestische vorlegen
statt
eine ähnliche doppelseite die erscheinen
und da hinten kritik gelbliche hatte
während die position lassen
genau wir können es nicht erklären das
ist völlig richtig weil nämlich um etwas
erklären zu können es in raum und zeit
stattfinden muss und hier haben wir es
eben einmal mit einem bereich zu tun der
nicht in der zeit stattfindet und von
dem wir auch keine empirische anschauung
haben wir haben von der freiheit und den
gründen keine wirkliche anschauung und
deswegen ist es schwierig das wirklich
ein zu sehen kann sagt wir können das
nicht einsehen aber wir können es
jedenfalls logisch modellieren und
logisch auf eine gewisse form schon auch
begreifen aber das sind ganz spannende
frage nach dem ästhetischen status diese
auflösung ein riesending will ich jetzt
auch nicht weiter vertiefen aber da kann
man natürlich dann auch ganz ins detail
gehen und schauen wie sich das mit
seiner praktischen philosophie verhält
hier geht es wirklich nur um die denkt
möglichkeit der vereinbarkeit von natur
determinismus und zwar vollständig
man könnte auch sagen harten
determinismus und diese freiheit und das
ist ein spannendes thema und das können
sie sehr gerne auch sich eben einer
hausarbeit vorsitzender nehmen sie sehr
viel nicht nur über kant sondern über
die gesamte debatte
und es wäre sehr spannend dieses thema
auch unter bezug auf gegenwärtige
freiheits theorien zu behandeln zum
beispiel pieter van in ruhigen mit dem
konsequenz argument und man könnte sich
fragen welche annahmen muss kann noch
machen was muss kann noch sagen als ich
einkaufen um diesen kompatibles muss hin
zu bekommen muss der und logische
verpflichtungen eingehen muss
irgendwelche zusatz annahmen machen oder
ja zusatz prämissen ins spiel um das
machen zu können wie etwa die
unterscheidung von trans den totalen
idealismus und trans allem realismus
man muss sich fragen inwiefern können
wir das verständlich machen ich habe
ihnen versucht ein angebot zu machen mit
dieser maxime die nicht zeitlich zu
denken ist eigentlich sollen die erwies
und fundierung verhältnisse denken ist
zu den handlungen der maxime die daraus
entspringen die sich dann in der zeit
manifestiert
das nur zu kant damit also viel gemacht
schwieriger stoff habe ich denke man
kann sehr viel lernen und jetzt kommen
wir zu diesem netten herrn weiss jemand
von ihnen werden das ist das ist
natürlich aristoteles ganz klar
natürlich schon vom 2 und er hat ein
ganz wichtiges weg geschrieben das ist
titel mit das sein und das nichts
und dieses werk ist 1943 erschien also
in schwierigen zeiten in europa war es
nicht so locker wie heute und das muss
man immer auch ein bisschen
berücksichtigen dass diesen schriften in
gewissen kontext entstanden sind sagt
natürlich nicht ihre geltung aus aber
sie werden gleich sehen wenn sie den
ersten zweiten satz lesen dass ihr
gewisse kontexte aufgerufen werden auch
an beispielen das entree ist ein sehr
politisch sozial engagierter denker der
viel mit der arbeiterschicht
sympathisiert gibt es immer beispiel
auch von arbeitern die arbeiterklasse so
redet man heutzutage ja gar nicht mehr
als man sieht schon dieses werk stammt
aus einem gewissen also eine gewisse
neue epoche und seite ist auch sehr
beeinflusst worden durch martin
heidegger den wir jetzt hier nicht lesen
konnten und durch die strömung der
phänomenologie als phänomenologie ist
eine philosophische strömung die
versucht dass sie was ich in der welt
ereignet vor allem das was durch
freiheit geschieht möglichst exakt zu
beschreiben
in seinen verschiedenen strukturen wie
es sich uns da bittet also eine sehr
sehr ambitionierte beschreibung theorie
der erscheinungen und wir wollen jetzt
mal hier ein ausschnitt aus diesem werk
lesen das gesamte werk habe ich auch in
die dropbox gestellt das gesamte welt
ein sehr schwieriges werk auch und wir
wollen jetzt uns ein paar leitfragen
hier vornehmen nämlich einmal
wie verhalten sich nach seine freiheit
und handlung zueinander
wir werden nämlich sehen dass fassade
der begriff der handlung sehr sehr
wichtig wird und nichts passiert der
begriff des willens
wie verhalten sich freiheit und
negativität zueinander wir müssten
genauer sagen negativ sagt nämlich nicht
negativität sondern hat einen speziellen
begriffe negativität und dann können wir
uns fragen ob sara er ein lieber tahrir-
ist oder eher ein kompatibel ist
wir sind also auch spannende fragen wo
jetzt gehen wir einfach mal mitten
hinein in den text und lesen mal weiter
er sagt es ist seltsam dass man endlos
über den determinismus und den freien
willen hat diskutieren und beispiele zu
gunsten der einen oder der anderen these
hat anführen können ohne vorher zu
versuchen die in der d des handelns
selbst enthaltenen strukturen zu klären
der begriff der handlung enthält ja
zeitliche untergeordnete begriffe
zahlreiche untergeordnete begriffe die
wir zu organisieren und zu realisieren
haben werden und dieses organisieren und
hier realisieren das ist geradezu dies
ist jedenfalls die aufgabe der
phänomenologie also diese klärung von
begriffen die aber auch mit empirischen
gestalten phänomen phänomenalen
gestalten zu tun haben das sind eine
gewisse ordnung zu bringen
also die orientierung an der handlung
zeigt mir scheint schon das sage ich ein
ganz starken phänomenologischen
hintergrund hat den kann so selbst nicht
hat kann interessiert sich sage jetzt
einfach mal so nicht so sehr für die
handlung sondern ihr für den willen sie
kennen alle vielleicht seine schrift
grundlegung zur metaphysik der sitten
das erkannt gut ist allein ein guter
wille und die handlung die aus dem
willen entspringt die ist nur so zu
verstehen wie eine einfassung eines
kostbaren juwels
juwel ist die der gute wille und die
handlung die aus dem guten willen
springt wie es zu vergleichen mit der
einfassung also mit dem metall oder mit
dem silber oder meinetwegen gold in dass
der juli gefasst ist alles eher eine
äußerlichkeit auch von wert und die
handlung ist bei kann immer erst
zweitrangig weil es interessiert kann
das motiv was der handlung zugrunde
lagen sondierungs charakter intel gibt
nur sache der sus erscheinung die
handlung ist immer eine erscheinung in
der welt und sagt jetzt nein andersrum
wir müssen uns hier mehr auf die
handlung konzentrieren weil die handlung
nicht so undifferenziert vorliegt
sondern sie enthält wie es halt
untergeordnete begriffe unser zahlreiche
die wir weiter strukturieren können
handeln heißt die gestalt der welt
verändern über mittel zu einem zweck
verfügen einen instrumentellen und
organisierten komplex hervorbringen das
durch eine reihe von verkettungen und
verbindungen die veränderung eines die
kettenglieder veränderung in der ganzen
reihe herbeiführt und schließlich ein
vorgesehenes resultat hervorbringen ok
also fast noch mal zusammen was ist
handeln handeln heißt welt verändern
es ist richtig da sehen sie bestimmt
schon auch das adresse politisch
engagiert war vertritt wollte die welt
verändern
das wollte kant nicht es wird auch kant
immer wieder vorgeworfen
das kann dann nur bei seinem willen
geblieben ist der wille der vor
allerhand und blickt der wille der nicht
in die zeit tritt oder nicht zeitlich
eigentlich verfasst ist der wille der
was intelligenz ist sagt er nein wir
wollen die handlung betrachten die die
welt verändert also weltveränderung also
engagement in die welt hinein
sich begeben sie kennen alle von martin
heidegger diese wendung dass in der welt
sein
das ist auch so etwas dem sattel wie mir
scheint verpflichtet ist dann mittel zu
einem zweck verfügen also man setzt sich
zwecke wobei der zweck ist ja eher die
pille sein wunsch also ein wille ist ja
etwas was ich mir sätze und woraufhin
ich arbeite dann wohin ich strebe oder
eine handlung bedeutet als auch wird die
mittel seinem zweck zu verfügen
als praktisch wir hatten ja einmal in
diesem seminar diese frage was ist der
unterschied zwischen einem wunsch mit
einem willen wissen sie noch mal diesen
unterschied
worin unterscheidet sich der wille von
einem bloßen wunsch
ja
genau der wunsch der hat nichts diese
wird den interessierten dieses mittel
nicht weil man nie weiß ich kann es
wahrscheinlich eh nicht mehr ich
wünschte ich wäre jetzt auf hawaii ich
kann es wünschen aber das kann ich mein
wille werden beim ich habe nicht die
mittel dazu als gut hier kommen die
mittel stärker ins spiel rein
instrumentellen und organisiert man
komplex hervorbringen das durch eine
reihe von verkettung und verbindungen
die veränderung eines der kettenglieder
veränderungen der ganzen reihe
herbeiführt und schließlich ein
vorgesehenes resultat hervorbringt als
ihm geht es jetzt ganz stark um die
produktion um das hervorbringen und die
realisierung von zwecken und da grund
geht es kann nicht so sehr aber darauf
kommt es noch nicht uns noch nicht an
zunächst muss man nämlich darauf
hinweisen dass ein handeln grundsätzlich
intentional ist der ungeschickte raucher
die aus versehen ein pulverfass in die
luft fliegen lässt hat nicht gehandelt
dagegen hat der arbeiter der in seinem
steinbruch eine sprengung ausführen
sollte und den auftrag erfüllt hat
gehandelt wenn er die vorgesehene
explosion herbeigeführt hat er wusste
nämlich was er machte oder wenn man
lieber will er realisierte intentional
ein bewusstes vorhaben
das bedeutet zwar nicht dass man alle
folgen in seiner handlung vor aussehen
muss als kaiser konstantin sich in
byzanz niederließ da er nicht voraus
dass er eine stätte griechische kultur
und sprache schaffen würde deren
entstehung später ein schisma in der
christlichen kirche aufgerufen
unser schwächung des römischen reiches
beitrag würde dennoch hat er gehandelt
insofern er sein vorhaben verwirklicht
hat für die kaiser eine neue residenz im
osten zu schaffen
die entsprechung von resultat um
intention ist hier nicht aushalten damit
wir von handeln sprechen kann
also was ist der unterschied zwischen
handeln und einem losen missgeschick wie
etwa das am ein pulverfass für die luft
geflogen ist
sie sehen sie verbindet immer auch
begriffe die mit ihm zusammen rauchen er
war ein ganz starker raucher als er
verwendet das nicht ohne grund
[Musik]
genau also die intention intentional
handeln muss grundsätzlich intentional
sein was ist den intentionen intention
ali t
das muss man unterscheiden von
internationalität so zwei verwandte aber
nicht den tischen begriffe oder das
immerhin schreiben also im tempo ziona
lied und internationalität
hier ist ein eltern hier sind themen wie
sind sie denn endlich unterschied
als intel die internationalität das wie
sie richtig sagen die absicht alles
ausgerichtet
lateinisch intendantin streben hin
gerichtet sein
und das ist auch ein grund begriff der
phänomenologie phänomenologie ist sagt
auch geht auch auf brentano zurück dass
also das geistige das was das geistige
auszeichnet ist dass durch gerichtet hat
ausgezeichnet als alle mentalen akte
sind insofern mental als sie eine
richtung haben als sie auf etwas
hinziehen
das ist für viele ein merkmal des
geistig das zentrale merkmal des geistes
zum beispiel ein wille ein wille ist
auch etwas hingerichtet auch ein gedanke
kann gerichtet sein und die intention
ist einfach nur der sinn intentional sie
kennt intention extension vielleicht
schon mal gehört die extension eines
wortes ist einfach eines begriffs muss
man genauer sagen ist der gegenstand der
unter ihnen fällt zum beispiel kann ich
den begriff universität bilden und dann
ist die extension zb diese universität
ihr aber auch eine andere universität im
anderen ort auch ein gegenstand der
darunter fällt gegenstand ist vielleicht
nicht so gut sagen wir stift der begriff
stift dann ist das die extension des
stiftes ein gegenstand der unter dem
begriff fällt und zum beispiel das fällt
nicht darunter
kein stück und intention eines begriffs
ist der sinn also die definition die
beschreibungen stift ist eben ein gerät
mit dem man schreiben kann und das hat
eine länge ungefähr nicht einen meter
sondern von
zwischen 10 und 30 cm so einfach die die
sie den sinn und nicht die referenz auf
die gegenstände in der welt also wir
internationalität heißt wir sind gericht
wir haben eine ausrichtung auf gewisse
gegenstände oder gewisse ziele und das
ist eben im falle eines bloßen
missgeschick es nicht der fall
der arbeiter wollte nicht dass das
pulverfass in die luft fliegt und zwar
wollte auch nicht gansel constantin ein
schisma herbeiführen
aber was ist der unterschied zwischen
dem bewirkten schisma also kaiser
konstantin hat bestimmt das schisma
irgendwie kausal herbeigeführt bei wenn
kaiser konstantin nicht konstantinopel
gegründet hätte wäre es nicht zu dem
schisma gekommen aber warum ist es jetzt
nicht derselbe wie dem pulverfass
diese diese gründung konstantinopels
warum ist das nicht leicht versetzt mit
gleichzusetzen mit der explosion eines
pulverfass
haben sie eine idee was wäre so ein
argument zu sagen das ist nicht dasselbe
sagt er sagt auch
ein einfacher grund wäre zum beispiel
dass man sagt diese schisma entstand die
erst viel später
na das war ja eine folge von vielen
zwischen mitgliedern schisma das hat
sich dann irgendwie heraus entwickelt
aber das konnte kaiser konstantin
überhaupt nicht vorweg sehen das hat
sich durch andere faktoren die da noch
mit reingespielt haben hingegen wenn ich
jetzt einfach eine zigarre oder
zigarette wegwerfen
damit ist das unmittelbar das pulver
fast explodiert
und deswegen ist das keine handlung in
dem sinne dass sie intendiert werden
weil das kann ein arbeiter nicht wollen
ich meine es könnte natürlich ein arbeit
auch die zigarette wegwerfen in der
absicht ein pulverfass zum explodieren
zu bringen
aber das war hier eben natürlich nicht
der fall ok also internationalität ein
wichtiger begriff wenn die aber so sein
soll dann stellen wir fest dass handeln
als seine bedingungen notwendig die
erkenntnis eines dezernats impliziert
das heißt eines objektiven mangels oder
aber eine negative
also wenn man das jetzt ist die
intention für rom eine rivalin zu
schaffen konstantinopel kann constantin
nur durch das erkennen eines objektiven
mangels kommen
rom braucht ein gegengewicht dieser noch
tief heiden stadt müsste man eine
christliche stadt gegenüber stehen die
im augenblick noch viel konzern opel
schaffen lässt sich nur dann als
handlung verstehen wenn zunächst die
konzeption einer neuen stadt dem handel
vorausgegangen ist oder wenn diese
konzeption wenigstens allen späteren
maßnahme als organisations thema den
aber diese konzeption kann nicht die
bloße vorstellung der stadt als möglich
sein
sie erfassen ihren wesensmerkmal das
darin besteht ein erwünschtes und nicht
realisiertes möglich ist
also was ist denn jetzt bitteschön eine
negative
haben sie eine idee
also handeln dass jetzt diese
phänomenologische könnte man sagen
analyse handeln setzt voraus ein
desiderat ohne ein desiderat würden wir
gar nicht so handeln anfangen es gibt
einen grund ein motiv für unser handeln
aber dieses motiv ist so verfasst dass
ist gerade nicht existiert zu spannenden
als sie werden nur dadurch zum handeln
verleitet dass etwas nicht ist was noch
sein soll das erst werden soll
als eine ganz seltsame struktur das
objekt des handels oder der grund des
handels ist etwas was noch nicht ist was
erst werden soll also aus einem mangel
heraus aus einem wunsch heraus ein
wunsch ist ja auch etwas was nur uns
vorschwebt gewissermaßen aber was eben
noch nicht wirklich ist das einen
mangelzustand wir werden nur durch
negative sachverhalte könnte man das
bezeichnen zum handeln motiviert also
handeln schließt eine ganz besondere
form von negativität mit ein
und das ist schon mal das ist jetzt der
zentrale begriff für ihn fest dass also
handeln mit negativität und über den
begriff der negativität möchtest dann
den begriff der freiheit wieder erklären
also negativität bedeutet zum einen auch
dass wir nicht durch etwas konkretes was
existiert bestimmt werden im handel sind
nämlich etwas was eben gerade noch nicht
existiert das bisschen paradox wie kann
in unser handeln bestimmt werden
durchweg weiß was noch nicht existiert
sondern erst durch das handeln wirklich
sein soll
das ist so dieser grundgedanke hören und
es kommt so ein bisschen vom
verfügbarkeit ins spiel
von unbestimmtheit auf eine gewisse
weise als es nicht real sind dass uns
als etwas reales bestimmen würde sondern
als etwas was ihr reha ist oder eben
negativ ist das bedeutet dass das
bewusstsein mit der konzeption der
handlung sich von der vollen wild von
der es bewusstsein ist hat zurückführen
und im bereich des seins verlassen
können
um gerade heraus den test nicht seins zu
betrieben
solange das was ist ausschließlich in
seinem sein betrachtet wird ist das
bewusstsein unaufhörlich vom seien auf
der sein verwiesen und kann im design
kein motiv finden das nicht sein zu
entdecken
das kaiser ihr system funktioniert
insofern rom seine hauptstadt ist
positiv und auf eine gewisse reale art
die sich leicht enthüllen lässt kann man
sagen dass die steuern schlecht eingehen
dass rom nicht vor den über suchen
geschützt ist dass es nicht die
geografische lage hat die der hauptstadt
eines von den barbaren bedrohten
mittelmeer reichs angemessen ist dass
der verfall der sitten die verbreitung
der christlichen religion erschwert wie
sollte man sehen dass alle diese
erwägungen negativ sind das heißt dass
sie das analysieren was nicht ist nicht
das was ist
also diese ganzen negativen sachverhalte
das nicht geschützt ist und so weiter
die sind der grund für die realisierung
einer handlung und was hatte jetzt was
ist also für das bewusstsein jetzt kommt
nämlich ein weiteres wichtiges wort ein
spieler wichtig der begriff jetzt kommt
der begriff des bewusstseins haben sie
eine idee wie man dieses wort diesen
begriff noch anders bezeichnen kann
mit satirischer terminologie in einem
der folgenden zitate bringt sarah diesen
begriff das ist ein typisch englischer
begriff das ist das für sich dafür ist
für mich ich beziehe mich auf mich dass
mein bewusstsein vielleicht müsste man
genauer sagt selbstbewusstsein ist immer
ein bisschen schwierig bewusstsein ganz
selbstlos zu unterscheiden weil das
bewusstsein das sind wir bewusst die
subjekte wir müssen um zu handeln um
handeln zu können um letztendlich auch
ein frei sein zu können müssen wir uns
zurückziehen aus der vollen welt mit
ihren positiven sachverhalten
das ist der fall das ist der fall das
ist der fall müssen wir uns zurückziehen
und den bereich wie sara sagt designs
verlassen und in das nicht seien
übertrieben
wir müssen wünsche ausbilden und das ist
auch immer so ein moment der negativen
freiheit wir müssen frei von etwas
werden um frei für etwas werden zu
können wir müssen uns aus dieser welt in
der wir gesetzt sind dieses in der welt
sein was uns eigentlich völlig erfüllt
aus der müssen wir rausgehen uns
befreien letztendlich von dieser vollen
welt und in das nicht sein übergehen das
heißt wir müssen entwürfe entwickelt
entwürfe uns vorsetzen entwürfe die eben
etwas betreffend was noch nicht der fall
ist was aber gerade sein sollte das soll
hier kommt natürlich auch ganz stark
politisches moment ins spiel denn sie
das werk ist nur
43 geschrieben worden oder
veröffentlicht worden vielleicht besser
das heißt das kann man durchaus auf
gesellschaftliches sachverhalt beziehen
sagt wenn wir sie alle wissen von den
sehr politisch denkender mensch könnte
also sagen man muss sich von den
gesellschaftlichen gegebenheiten
befreien und eine vision ich sage jetzt
nicht revolution aber so ein anderer
entwurf entgegen setzt die eben noch
nicht ist halten wir dürfen unsere
wusste ja nicht unaufhörlichen
unaufhörlich von sein auf das sein
verwiesen werden weil dann haben wir
kein motiv ein beweggrund das nicht sein
natürlich könnte man sich jetzt fragen
haben wir nicht auch im losen seien ein
motiv ihm sein wenn wir auf der seite
verließen sind ja gut aber dann wird uns
geben alles nur angeboten
das ist dann sowieso eine schlechte
willkür wir haben hier ein angebot hier
in angebot ihren angeboten dass sein in
all seiner ganzen bandbreite und wir
können das wählen das wäre das wählen
aber da wird es sein das ist eben eine
schlechte form von willkür in der fülle
des seins aufzugeben sondern um eine
richtige form von freiheit entwickelt zu
müssen müssen wir selbst entwürfe
entwürfe am realisieren und entwürfe
realisieren bedeutet sich etwas
vorzusetzen was uns die welt nicht
anzubieten hat etwas zu wollen was wir
nicht durch einen einfachen griff in das
seien die philips 14 der welt
realisieren können so etwas was wir uns
erst mal gedanklich entwerfen müssen was
noch nicht ist was wir erst durch die
aufwendung der mittel realisieren müssen
das ist also die bedeutung der
negativität und es lesen einfach mal
weiter als er sagt hier ist es kein
faktischer zustand wie er auch sei
politische wirtschaftliche struktur der
gesellschaft psychologischer zustand und
so weiter kann von sich aus irgend eine
handlung motivieren das hoch politisch
natürlich jetzt zu verstehen also das
hat denn eine handlung ist eine
projektion das für sich also des
bewusstseins auf das was nicht ist und
das was ist kann in keiner weise von
sich aus das bestimmen was nicht ist
inwiefern sehen sie jetzt da eine
freiheits theoretische positionen teil
wie würden sie jetzt denn die erste
these hier mit einem begriff der
modernen freiheits debatte
klassifizieren
ist es eher die position des
determinismus oder in er die position
des innenministers
hmm
weil laut aus was nicht ist ihr spiel
als erbe sondern sie sagen die ganze
welt so wie sie vor kindlich ist die
determiniert uns nicht vollständig wir
sind nicht vollständig durch die welt
determiniert und war der segen weil wir
die möglichkeit des negativen haben alle
unsere zwecke die eben noch zustände
bezeichnen die eben noch nicht wirklich
sind alle diese zwecke können weil sie
eben nicht sind gar nichts vom seien
bestimmte leute in das argument ein oder
eben nicht sehr bald steht der indische
minister dann ist eine negative freiheit
halten von den sozialen umständen aber
leuchtet in das 1
genau das kam mir als auch auf den
ersten blick können nicht auch die
negativen sachverhalte die wünsche
produkt auch wenn sie eben wünsche sind
und noch nicht realisiert sind
das seien des zustandes in dem wir uns
befinden also sind wir nicht auch in
unseren negativen sachverhalten
negativen wünschen unserer negativität
letztendlich determiniert durch eben die
welt wie sie ist
das scheint mir ein bisschen
problematisch zu sein was ich meine rein
logistisch gesehen natürlich das was
noch nicht ist kann nicht bestimmt seien
durch das was ist das ist klar aber es
tut sie sich doch ein solcher fall
denken zum beispiel mehr haben wollen
von etwas was wir schon haben
wenn ich noch mehr haben möchte dann
will ich etwas was noch nicht ist aber
ich will das was noch nicht ist als
bloße fortsetzung des jähnigen was ist
verstehe ich möchte einfach nur eine
graduelle steigerung haben
ich bin reich aber ich möchte noch
reicher werden
ich bin noch nicht noch reicher aber die
ist es noch reicher werden wollen ist
nur zu verstehen als eine ganz
konsequente fortsetzung meines
ist-zustandes könnte das so aussehen
oder es ist ein problem also
das ist für mich jedenfalls nicht so
ganz klar also wir diese negativ hier
versteht ja zweiter punkt kein
faktischer zustand kann das bewusstsein
dazu bestimmen das seite 757 ist es dazu
bestimmen in als negativ oder mangel zu
erfassen mehr noch kein faktischer
zustand kann das bewusstsein dazu
bestimmen ihn zu definieren und zu
umschreiben
naja wie wir gesehen haben der satz kino
saß determination ist die katze also
jede determination ist eine negation
also jene bestimmung ist eine negation
zutiefst war bleibt also hat jedes
handeln zur ausdrücklichen bedingung
nicht nur die entdeckung eines zustands
als mangel an das heißt als negativ
sondern auch und zuvor die
konstituierung des betrachteten zustands
als isolierte systeme
es gibt einen faktischen zustand
predigen oder nicht nur durch das nicht
tun es vermögen das sich aber dieses
nicht unvermögen kann sich nicht darauf
beschränken einen bloßen abstand
gegenüber der welt zu realisieren was
ist denn jetzt hier ein nicht unvermögen
[Musik]
ich denke durchaus genau ja also dieses
bewusstsein ist ihm immer reflexion und
der reflexion können wir eben uns die
welt so wie sie faktisch ist auch ganz
anders repräsentieren
ich dachte hier zum beispiel auch an
sowas wie fantasie bringt er jetzt nicht
ausdrücklich ins spiel wenn ich über die
welt so wie sie ist reflektieren kann
dann kann ich sie mir eben auch anders
denken habe ich zum beispiel die
fähigkeit in mir wie robert musil kennen
sie den mann ohne eigenschaften den
protagonisten ulrich der hat einen
möglichkeit sinn der sagt wo es einen
wirklichkeitssinn gibt dann muss es auch
eine möglichkeit sind das heißt durch
unser selbstbewusstsein oder bewusstsein
können wir uns vorstellen wie es auch
ganz anders sein könnte
es muss nicht so sein wie es ist es
könnte auch ganz anders sein oder es
hätte auch ganz anders kommen können als
wir können die welt nicht nur unter dem
gesichtspunkt ihrer faktizität verstehen
sondern auch im sinne ihrer kontingents
sie ist nicht notwendigerweise so wie
sie ist sie könnte auch ganz anders sein
das wäre vielleicht eine eine
beschreibung dieses nicht das vermögen
das habe ich glaube nicht dass vermögen
müssen ein bisschen mehr sein
wie verstehen sie denn dass wir diese
liste termin ac ist negation also jede
bestimmung ist auch eine regierung
haben sie da eine idee wie wir in diesen
satz verstehen kann jede bestimmung
nämlich etwas stimme negiere ist auch
zugleich ich kann man das verstehen
haben sie eine idee
ist eigentlich ziemlich trivial was
müssen sie denn machen um einen stift zu
bestimmen
das müssen sie dann machen zb genau ich
kann immer auch bestimmen indem ich ab
grenze von anfang an bestimmen heißt
auch immer aber fest zb kennen sie alle
kennen sie also auf griechisch heißt zum
beispiel begriff oder definition
horizont horizont heißt einfach nur
abgrenzen oder die definition das eine -
steckt ja auch drin das ende vielleicht
nicht ganz so klar aber der orgasmus ist
einfach nur die abgrenzung von anderen
also stift ist eben kein mobiltelefon
ohne ist auch keine fernbedienung oder
ist auch keine höhlen
darin ist natürlich nicht gesagt was er
eigentlich ist aber jedenfalls gehört
dazu immer auch eine abgrenzung von
anderen um etwas bestimmen zu können
das stift ist nicht dass das eigene art
als wir kommen eben immer wieder
wenn wir es mit bewusstsein zu tun haben
werden wir jetzt mit reflexivität zu tun
haben immer wieder in die situation dass
wir etwas negieren dass wir ist auch zb
reflektieren und anders wenden
als er möchte hier ganz stark der bfr
negativität stark machen der für ihn
eben würde weniger die möglichkeit ist
für freiheit ja bitte
[Musik]
genau und das will sie offensichtlich
bestreiten also ja genau also sarah
möchte genau das bestreiten möchte also
er also eigentlich könnte man ja sagen
wie sie richtig sagen alles war es
später ist was noch nicht ist ergibt
sich eigentlich durch die gesetze und
den ist zustand genau also ist der harte
determinismus und das war ja so ein
bisschen unser argument sie sehen hier
also das ist formal wir haben null oder
so was auch immer und die venus
eigentlich brauchen wir gar nicht die
die enbw 0 und das geblieben wie 1
zugesprochen hat wenn wir gesetze haben
und den jetzigen zustand können wir
jeden beliebigen bild zustand der noch
nicht ist de dozieren ökologisch aus den
vorhergehenden usa und seite würde das
aber gerade bestreiten er würde sagen
nein wir können es deswegen nicht weil
wir ein phänomen betrachten müssen was
sich nicht naturalistisch erfassen lässt
sondern so etwas wie die hand betrifft
die handlung die hat man wünsche und
ziele und die wünsche und ziele die
können wir nicht herleiten aus diesen
ganzen naturgesetzen das hat aber der
kommilitone und ich habe auch so ein
fall vorgebracht hat
aber kann ich irgendwie das soziale die
soziale gegebenheit uns doch darin
bestimmen was wir tun oder was wir uns
wünschen
das kann ich das negative letztendlich
doch ein produkt sein
aus unseren sein und denkt das ganze
eben sehr logisch und sehr formal dass
es sagt nein aus logischen gründen kann
das was nicht ist gar nicht bestimmt
seien durch das was schon ist
es entzieht sich der bestimmung durch
das seien diese negativ
ein negativer sachverhalten dann kann
man sich natürlich fragen jetzt gegen st
er wird offensichtlich keinem
determinismus vertreten so viel wissen
kein predator - und jetzt müssen wir
eben kritisch zu rückfragen ist immer so
wenn man keinen determinismus vertritt
wir vertreten dann einen in den termin
ist ja also ist dann das das negative
was ich das entree vorsitzt völlig
beliebig und überhaupt nicht bestimmt
kommt das ganze dann aus dem nichts
heraus
also wenn sie jetzt mal ist jetzt diese
theorie sich anschauen
mit welcher position würden sie denn
dann zahlt ersten jetzt hier in
verbindung mit welcher freiheits
theoretischen position wie würden sie
sagte jetzt nennen von dem was sie
bisher wissen geben drei möglichkeiten
dafür
sie seien kompatibel ist sein revier ist
ein der termin ist oder ist er gar ein
mysterium ist was ist in ihren augen am
ehesten
also sie sagen ja an die bavaria würde
ich auch sagen also mir scheint ja auch
am ehesten ein lieber tahrir- zu sein
müssen aber noch ein bisschen weiter
lesen wir haben jetzt noch fünf minuten
und wir haben noch ein paar zitate
insofern nämlich das bewusstsein durch
das sein umzingelt ist insofern es
einfach das erleidet was ist muss es in
das eingeschlossensein organisierte
gestalt sein leiden natürlich finden der
arbeiter muss bewundern und negiert
werden damit sie den gegenstand 1
enthüllen betrachtung bilden kann das
bedeutet natürlich dass der arbeiter
durch ein bloßes sich losreißen von sich
selbst und von der welt sein leiden als
unerträglich ist leiden setzen und
infolgedessen es zum antrieb seines
revolutionären handelns machen kann sich
sehen das ist aus einer anderen zeitung
für das bewusstsein impliziert dass die
permanent die möglichkeit mit seiner
eigenen vergangenheit zu brechen sich
von ihr los zu reisen um sie im licht
eines nicht seins betrachten und ihre
bedeutung verleihen zu können die sie
hat vom entwurf eines sinns aus den sie
nicht hat in keinem fall und auf keine
weise kann die vergangenheit von sich
aus eine handlung hervorbringt das heißt
die setzung eines zwecks der sich zu ihr
zurück findet um sie zu beleuchten und
das ist jetzt ein argument gegen den den
determinismus diesen starken
determinismus das hatte er geahnt als
schrieb der geist ist das negative
obwohl er sich daran erinnert zu haben
scheint als er seine eigene nicht
erinnert zu haben scheint als er seine
eigene theorie des handels und der
freiheit
da legen sollte sobald man ja den
bewusstsein dieses negative vermögen der
welt und sich selbst gegenüber
zuschreibt sobald den nicht tom
integrierender teil der setzung eines
zwecks ist muss man anerkennen dass die
unerlässliche und grundlegende bedingung
jedes handels die freiheit des handelns
ältere französisch ist da muss natürlich
jetzt hier noch ein axel draufgesetzt
hat das programm leider nicht erkannt
dabei wollen jetzt noch ein bisschen
verweilen sagen sie mir noch in den
letzten drei minuten was ist jetzt mit
diesem zitat auf sich hat ich glaube
dass das das zentrale argument enthält
wenn sie dieses argument verstanden
haben brauchen sie gar nicht mehr
weiterlesen
deswegen wollen wir uns jetzt noch mal
ganz kurz
der entscheidende satz scheint mir das
hier zu sein für das bewusstsein
impliziert dass die permanente
möglichkeit mit seiner eigenen
vergangenheit zu brechen also sie nicht
nur fortzusetzen sondern sieht man einen
ganz neuen licht zu sehen sich von ihr
los zu reißen um sie im lichte eines
nicht seins betrachten das ist praktisch
der möglichkeit sind negative vermögende
gerungs vermögen und ihr die bedeutung
auch nicht die gericht die bedeutung
verleihen zu können die sie hat vom
entwurf eines sets ins aus denen sie
nicht hat also wir sind in einem sein
gesetzt wir sind vorbildlich
befindlichkeit und der heiliger sein und
durch unser bewusstsein und
selbstbewusstsein können wir uns dazu in
einer distanz begeben wir können es
heraus reflektieren wir können uns einen
entwurf machen der nicht ist also
wichtigkeit ist von dem entwurf aus
gesehen dann das bisherige sein einen
ganz neuen sinn bekommt dass es versagt
wird der versuch aus dem determinismus
auszubrechen aus diesen konsequenz
argument auszubrechen weil das ganze
sich auf sich zurück wendet in keinem
fall und auf keine weise kann die
vergangenheit des der determinismus von
sich aus eine handlung hervorbringen
das heißt setzung eines zwecks der sich
zu ihr zurück wendet um sie zu
beleuchten
das ist das ist das kernargument also es
so wir haben hier eine situation das ist
dass sein
wir haben das sein
und jetzt haben wir hier aber nicht nur
dass sein sondern wir haben das fürs für
sich sein dass für sein an das
selbstbewusstsein das bezieht sich auf
sich selbst und in dem sich auf sich
selbst bezieht macht es einen entwurf
ist das nichts
und damit noch nicht genug durch diesen
entwurf bezieht wird das seien plötzlich
in einem neuen licht erscheinen
und das sagt kein der termin ist muss
kein deterministische ereignis kann ein
solches phänomen erklären dass du weißt
dass das determinierte sich zurück
bezieht auf das determinieren
determinierte ist lose folge
also es hat sozusagen keine macht über
das was ihm vor weg nach st er hat aber
das was vorweg steht was der zukunft
steht eine macht über das sein vater ist
ein ganz großer revolutionär da sie
sehen also ich lese diese passage völlig
politisch noch ein politischer aussagen
müssen uns befreien aus dem verhältnis
ist jetzt ein ganz starkes soziales
engagement der zweck selbst ist nicht
nur sohn produkten zukunftsentwurf der
wirkungslos wäre es nicht im lichte des
entwurfs verändern wir das seien aus dem
heraus wir den entwurf erst gemacht
haben also es war eine selbst bezahlte
eine reflexive struktur der entwurf
wendet sich zurück auf das seien aus dem
meer entsprungen ist dass die grund
figur jetzt muss man versuchen diese
grund figur näher zu erläutern und
freiheits theoretisch zu beschreiben
ich habe einige fragen auf so zum
beispiel wie steht's mit dem
determinieren dem moment wo kommt ihr
eine bestimmte zeit ins spiel
oder handelt es sich bloß um bloße
indifferenz in determinismus ich würde
auch sagen ist ein libertarian es muss
aber ein reflektierter die beta
realismus aber wir müssen uns fragen wo
kommt hier dann die bestimmtheit
spielt und ist es am ende nicht eine
bloße form von willkürlichkeit damit
wollen wir es auch belassen für heute
und auch für das ganze semester sie
sehen wir haben ja noch ein paar schöne
zitat hätten wir noch übrig die finden
sie aber alle demnächst auf die lowcost
wo sie übrigens auch eine neue
komposition von mir finden
vielleicht haben sie schon gesehen wir
machen jetzt auch immer ein bisschen
musik schauen sie mal auf vorbei auf die
lowcost und geben sie diesem lied ein
like wenn sie es dann wünsche ich ihnen
jetzt noch eine schöne vorlesungsfreie
zeit nicht biete auch in der nächsten
morgen nochmal sprechstunden an
ich werde ihnen da nachrichten herr und
mehr schreiben dann eine schöne
vorlesungsfreie zeit